I will do everything to defend this your
writing
we at screens take the battle I would
propose rather you which is scale back
we have work to do
migration is an opportunity it's time we
introduced minimum wage in every member
state they are all running for the EU
Commission president's job
Margaret of astanga for the Liberals
Scott Keller for the Greens Manfred
Weber for the Conservatives France
Timmerman's for the Social Democrats
yawns our deal is conservative reformist
candidate and Nico Kui is for the party
they are the six leading European
candidates but hang on a minute who are
they and does anyone know anything about
them do you know any of them yeah I do
you know him no any idea no no have you
ever seen her no Dutchman France
Timmerman speak some languages he wants
more social justice German month will be
by is calling for secure Europe hub for
example by European FBI
Denmark's Margaret vest agar is standing
for a self-confident EU and women's
rights left-wing Nico key from Belgium
is a trade unionist and is fighting for
social rights
the Germans kakera is promoting a
European climate friendly future the
Czech Republic's Yun's our deal is in
favor of the EU but once more
sovereignty for individual nation states
they are all committed to the European
Union but what are the biggest
challenges what solutions do they need
to offer for the future the
fragmentation between member states a
lot of distrust which we have which has
increased over the past years between
member states also between national
capital and brussels stager and social
democrat france Timmerman's
are the only candidates who have already
had some experience as a minister is
that an advantage for the job obviously
it is an asset if you have had
experience at national level because in
many cases national political parties
are not really supportive of their
European Schmitz and Canada and they're
not pushing them they're rather
in their own national candidates so you
don't see visually that they exist but
one man has definitely been in the
spotlight on the European stage Michel
Barnier who could be the Joker in the
pack he's not officially a candidate but
he might just end up getting the job as
the well-regarded brexit negotiator he
enjoys the respect and trust of many
heads of state and government and in the
end that could be way more important
than a load of TV debates for more on
this I'm joined now by our correspondent
gieok Montes in Brussels gieok 6:00
formal candidates for a used top job but
there could still be a surprise how so
exactly the European Parliament of
course hopes that one of the lead
candidates there one of their candidates
who has been campaigning for the big
political group in the European
Parliament will grab that top position
in the European Commission but it could
also as we've seen in the report be
someone who has been campaigning rosser
rather decently in in behind the scenes
if you want to put it like that that is
the chief practice negotiator Michel
Barnier
because at the end of the day it is up
to the leaders the heads of state and
government who are in the driving seat
of the European Union they are the ones
who can pick a candidate a candidate
that is proposed by the European Council
President and that candidate then has to
be approved by the European Parliament
so it's a tricky process and that is why
it's not yet clear who will grab that
job the EU and EU elections are
incredibly complex by design and voters
have switched off in great numbers in
the past elections how big is interest
in the election this time around well
the European Parliament this time round
seeing that the participation rates have
been dropping over the years and decades
has made a huge effort this time send
out volunteers made campaign videos
invested a lot of money so that people
do understand what this election is
about why it is important that people go
and vote directly this the European
Parliament is the own
be part of the European Union where you
have a direct chance to pick your
candidate where when democracy is if you
want to put it that way the most vivid
and so of course the hope is that
turnout will be bigger this time which
is also important looking towards
right-wing parties and their impact
because if the turnout is bigger the
impact of the far-right in Europe will
be marginalized
yeah the Nationalists and Euroskeptic
movement is expected to draw a lot of
support is it really gonna reflect as
such in in the balance look that's of
course the big question and and we don't
know yet as all elections it can be full
of surprises we've seen in the
Netherlands that all of a sudden the
Social Democrats cake came up first of
course if you look at the opinion polls
in France for instance the Faunus
Journal of marine lepen the far right is
or is in a narrow lead ahead of the
French president which would be quite a
success if they would come out strongest
party then in Italy the leak of material
salvini the French the italian Foreign
Minister is the quickest growing party
in Europe so undoubtedly the
Nationalists will make bigger gains in
this election the big question then
after the election and that is something
we will have to look at it on Monday is
how will they be able to form groups at
the moment they are split amongst a
number of groups in the European
Parliament's if they will manage to form
one big group they could have of course
a much stronger impact in politics in
Europe a wide ideological spectrum
represented on the ballot papers today
and in the past couple of days what
issues have the parties focus on during
their campaigns well for the far right
of course migration was still a topic
although I've talked to a number of
voters tomorrow when this morning in
Belgium when I cast my ballot in and
migration wasn't one of the big topics
people have realised that numbers have
dropped dramatically but a lot of young
people in particular said they have
turned up because the environment is
important to them and for instance
yesterday
there was a big march on the environment
where create a tomb Berg the Swedish
student campaigner for the environment
against environmental damage has asked
people to go out and vote in this
European election so I think we could
see in this European election a shift a
big gain for green parties that at least
as what was my impression was this this
morning and that's also the picture I
get from a number of other states where
opinion polls have said that the green
parties could be a surprise winner of
this election twz Eric mattes and
Brussels thank you very much